le pdg d'airbus est de passage au québec
guillaume faury a visité l'usiné
d'assemblage de la 220 en compagnie du
premier ministre françois legault et du
ministre de l'économie pierre fait du
québec le programme de la 220
anciennement la cseries appartient
désormais à 75 % à airbus 25% au
gouvernement du québec
guillaume faury pdg d'airbus et à
mirabel il est notre invité ce soir
bonsoir monsieur faurie bonsoir vous
êtes à mirabel
aujourd'hui vous n'aviez pas d'annoncé
particulière mais quand même vous pouvez
vous nous parler de vos ambitions pour
le québec
alors on a pas d'annoncé parce qu'elles
ont été faites la semaine dernière mais
le changement de structure dans airbus
canada est très important pour nous on a
maintenant 75 % de de la joint-venture
comme on dit avec investissement québec
et ce réinvestissement d'airbus montre
l'ambition qu'on a pour le programme à
220 le ce qui s'appelait le cseries
précédemment et la confiance qu'on a
dans le programme le fait qu on
réinvestit le fait qu'on construit
l'avenir de ce programme donc c'était
une rencontre avec les employés les
équipes
le management est aussi le premier
ministre du québec françois legault et
monsieur fit steven qui sont nos
nouveaux associés dans cette
joint-venture et je pense pour
nombreuses années pour le succès du
programme et donc est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il vend actuellement lorsque
vous allez poursuivre ce développement
du programme de la 220 bien que il est
prévu qu'airbus rachète la part du
gouvernement du québec en 2026 mais
est-ce que d'ici là il serait possible
que vous demandiez au gouvernement du
québec d'investir davantage alors la
façon dont est organisée la relation
entre airbus et investissement québec
dans la joint-venture c'est que les
obligations de financement sont portés
par la joint-venture et avec
l'investissement d'airbus
donc je vous laisserai posé la question
à monsieur fils guy bono ce qui concerne
leurs intentions mais on est dans une
situation où les financements sont
apportés par la joint-venture et par
airbus pour l'instant votre objectif
était de réduire les coûts de la 222 au
moins 20 % en trois ans est ce que vous
y êtes arrivé jusqu'à maintenant
alors en effet pour garantir la réussite
sur le long terme du programme
il faut des ventes des succès
commerciaux et ça ça marche très bien
il faut faire la montée en cadence
industrielle et on y passe beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'énergie une partie des
investissements sont là pour assurer
cette montée en cadence industrielle et
il faut aussi réduire les coûts et donc
on est effectivement sur la trajectoire
qu'on s'était défini à 18 mois pour
aller réduire les coûts d'environ 20%
donc on n'y est pas encore mais on est
sur la bonne trajectoire est ce que vous
prévoyez développer d'autres programmes
que celui de la de saint-vaast au québec
alors écoutez c'est déjà beaucoup
la 220 c'est un des très gros programme
maintenant d'airbus
on est dans la phase d'investissement on
continuera probablement investir sur des
variantes de l'appareil mais ça c'est
pour plus tard
et puis en ce qui concerne d'autres
ambitions oui on aimerait bien faire des
choses dans les autres domaines
d'activité qui sont ceux d'airbus
l'aviation commerciale et le principal
de ses activités mais on a aussi des
activités dans le spatial dans la
défense et c'est des sujets on aimerait
beaucoup faire grandir la relation avec
le québec et plus généralement avec le
canada et le jour où on aura ou
voudraient investir davantage dans la
220 à 220 plus long par exemple est-ce
que ça se ferait en alabama en europe ou
à bira belle alors on n'est pas encore
au moment de développer une version
allongée ça fait partie des choses qui
sont dans les noms les idées dans les
projets ça viendra probablement plus
tard ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la conduite de programmes
le centre névralgique du programme à 220
il est ici et donc les développements
successifs de l'avion qui se feront à
partir d'ici et les essais les
prototypes l'industrialisation se fera
ici à mirabel
après on est une entreprise très globale
et si on doit avoir d'autres activités
industrielles ailleurs pour garantir la
réussite le développement est passé des
choses qu'on fera mais il faut encore
c'est le centre névralgique
il est ici et il va rester ici bien
entendu est ce que en 2026 quand vous
allez racheter la part
gouvernement du québec sait maintenant
ce qui est au contrat officiellement
est ce que vous prévoyez que le
programme sera à ce moment-là à sa
pleine valeur
alors on verra en 2026 il ya beaucoup de
travail d'ici là mais il est
effectivement très probable il est dans
nos plans que le programme soit devenu
profitable d'ici là et donc ce soit un
moment approprié pour le québec de
sortir de la joint-venture et laisser le
projet voler de ses propres ailes
complètement avec airbus d'ici là il ya
beaucoup d'investissements affaire
airbus est ici et là est présent pour
faire ces investissements
donc on est encore dans une phase où on
dépense beaucoup d'argent pour la
réussite du programme
oui vous avez annoncé 2300 suppressions
de postes en europe dans les divisions
défense et spatial c'était hier
est-ce que des cons près de
décompression du même genre sont aussi à
prévoir dans l'aviation commerciale
alors chaque activité doit être
compétitive
et puis il ya en plus des hausses et des
baisses d'activité suivants les
différents secteurs
il se trouve que dans le spatial ce
dernières années ça a été très difficile
on est dans un changement de modèle
d'affaires et donc il faut s'adapter
il faut en permanence s'adapter c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire aujourd'hui
dans l'activité défense dans l'activité
espace c'était le cas il ya quelques
années dans l'activité hélicoptères
quand il ya eu la crise du secteur
pétrolier offshore pour nous on n'est
pas dans cette situation dans l'aviation
commerciale
au contraire elle est en croissance et
on al impression que l est en croissance
pour de nombreuses années
donc voilà il faut faire face aux
situations comme elles viennent et en
permanence avoir en tête que ce qui
garantit l'avenir ce qui garantit les
emplois ce qui garantit la croissance
c'est la compétitivité d'une activité le
15 février dernier l'administration
trump a annoncé que les taxes imposées
aux avions d'airbus importés d'europe
vont passer de 10 à 15%
qu'est ce que vous faites face ce type
de taxes qui augmentent alors
effectivement c'est une situation qui
nous paraît très inapproprié qui résulte
d'une dispute entre l'europe et les
états unis sur des subventions pour les
avions
et en europe et aux états unis on attend
pour le mois de mai la décision de l'om
c'est dans le cas europe contre états
unis qui devrait donner à l'europe
le droit de mettre en place également
des tarifs d'importation au global nous
on pense que c'est perdant-perdant et on
l'appelle de nos voeux nous airbus le
fait qu'ils aient une nouvelle
négociation pour un accord et qui permet
de continuer à faire des affaires sans
taxes sans tarifs parce qu'en fait on
est dans un écosystème que j'appelle
atlantique nord etats unis canada europe
et qu'il faut préserver la compétitivité
de cet écosystème
donc on espère que les phases qui
viennent vont permettre de faire
descendre et d'annuler ces tarifs qui
sont aujourd'hui un vrai problème pour
notre industrie absolument guillaume
faury vous êtes à mirabel
merci d'avoir pris ces quelques minutes
avec nous ce soir avec plaisir à
l'endroit remercie